est-ce qu'on peut encore gagner la coupe
du monde de rugby oui c'est une question
de santé la santé d'Antoine Dupont
Antoine Dupont on a dit qu'il avait une
fracture de la mâchoire c'est un peu
faux et un peu vrai à la fois la
mâchoire elle est faite en deux parties
le maxillaire supérieur et le maxillaire
inférieur qu'on appelle aussi la
mandibule si c'était fracturé la
mandibule ça aurait été plus embêtant
mais là Antoine Dupont il a une fracture
maxilozigomatique au niveau de la
pommette il a été opéré on lui a mis
deux petites plaques de métal et la
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il va jouer le
quart de finale il va jouer avec un
casque un casque de rugby mais à quoi ça
sert ça sert à deux chose d'abord le
casque il est fait dans une matière qui
amortit les chocs ça va absorber les
vibrations quand il va prendre des coups
sur la tête et puis il y a un autre truc
qui est dangereux quand on joue blesser
c'est l'appréhension parce qu'un joueur
qui a peur non seulement il est moins
bon mais en plus il a plus de risque de
se reblesser parce qu'il joue pas comme
d'habitude il a pas les mêmes réflexes
donc avec un casque Antoine d pont il
sera aussi plus en confiance mais alors
est-ce qu'on peut toujours gagner la
Coupe du Monde oui mais il va falloir
protéger Antoine d pont sur le terrain
sil reprend un coup au même endroit ça
va piquer